Imaginem que seu organismo é como um
carro Você não colocaria um combustível
ruim nele certo então por que fazemos
isso com o nosso corpo os óleos vegetais
comuns contém algo chamado Aurino leico
que é praticamente um veneno metabólico
quando em excesso como se estivéssemos
abastecendo o nosso carro com um
combustível adulterado esses olhos
também conhecidos Como ômega-6 atuam
como a verdadeira toxina metabólica e na
verdade as gorduras ômega-6 precisam
estar em sintonia com as gorduras
ômega-3 para que não se tornem
prejudiciais no entanto esse equilíbrio
quase nunca acontece na alimentação
moderna recheada de produtos Ultra
processados os óleos vegetais a base de
sementes como soja milho Girassol canola
parecem inofensivos mas são verdadeiros
agentes inflamatórios e produtores de
estresse oxidativo a maior parte do
ômega-6 desses óleos já chega a nosso
prato já oxidado e danificado graças ao
processamento a que são submetidos